[Music]
please welcome Dwayne Perkins oh thank
you so much thank you guys so good to be
here I'm glad to be here with you guys
like you guys are paying attention like
we don't we don't do this anymore right
no one pays attention where it just
slaves to our devices we are not
sometimes that's why I just want to go
back sometimes I just want to go back
yeah you know what I'm saying lady I
want to go back not not too far back
obviously
[Applause]
me black me we don't like to go too far
just not just 95 nothing crazy
you know I mean there's wonder like like
12 years ago you could just be wrong
remember remember just being wrong like
you said something and the other person
was like well you know it doesn't sound
right but uh I guess we'll never know I
guess which is half it good to live our
lives is the thing we have to do and the
problem with the whole thing is no
matter how dumb you are you are dumber
on Facebook because there's no one there
to stop you like it it seems like a good
idea I got a buddy
he wrote a love poem to this girl's okay
major fail and it's to a married woman
yeah and I was like when I read him like
what are you doing like who taught you
how to creep just send her a message
what's wrong with you it was so bad is
that I was gonna take a break apply to
grad school take out student loans get
into a grad school two-year program
study my butt off get all A's move up to
the Bay Area graduate get a master's
degree in computer science get a job at
Facebook just so I could delete his
account I was gonna do all
[Music]
and I get it you want to tell people
things I get it but what surprises me is
why do people care that's what that's
what changed is this our fault
like we collectively encourage this
behavior yes awful if you don't believe
me go home tonight type anything on your
page type anything type I like almonds
and eight other people will like it yeah
I like almonds too actually good calm on
the almonds going no he's right about
that almonds are delicious he's
absolutely right about that I'm just
glad someone had the courage to say it
actually why is that acceptable but
leave here tonight and just start
walking up on people saying I like
almonds and they'll arrest you it's what
will happen and I don't you know listen
I'm not I'm not I don't mean to be a
technophobe but I also think video games
are done I think there's no place to go
from there's no think about video games
think of the evolution first video game
ever what's called pong there's a knob
just a ball going across the screen just
hours of enjoyment for the people who
around and when people saw pong their
minds were blown they're so pointy like
the future is now that's what they said
but then it got better right they say
you know what give us the knob here's a
joystick like oh wow
shut the front do I get a button are you
serious you had a joystick then it got
better the graphics got better I said
give us a choice it back here's a
controller like all fancy friend so you
could multiple buttons combinations are
you can you were cooking with gas
then the controller was not connected to
anything was Wireless you were like oh
snap I'm gonna catch you right in the
house yeah then H they give us that
controller back hey just take this
skinny thing just take this you like
whoa just this thing this is crazy
you were bowling with your mom pick up
the spare my then they said give us that
thing back give us that thing back
nothing just you you like just me you
were funny at TV playing football but
deep do you see the problem with that
you you could always play football is
the thing you have to understand
you can play football fifty years ago so
what was it all for 30 years of video
games for you to be in front of TV like
a jackass dancing so I think there's one
more video game system that's gonna come
out just one more people gonna line up
for it's gonna cost $400 come in a
silver box gonna take that thing home
open it up and inside it's gonna say
just take a south side that's good
[Applause]